each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so we've had uh a number of
really interesting talks uh I'm glad to
see everyone looks alert and has a lot
of energy for the afternoon session uh
uh Garnett Chang is going to start us
off in the afternoon session with uh
lecture on Quantum information and for
quantum chemistry gett okay than much uh
it's uh very interesting to be in this
meeting
um oh oh yeah
sorry the one the one thing I had to
do all right now we can start again okay
so uh so as I was saying it's very it's
really very interesting to be here and
to meet uh to meet all the different
people and in in a different community
and also to be in a different setting so
I think I was telling Marcus this is the
first time I've been outside of an
academic environment uh it's not really
so different it's just you know the the
food is nicer and the chairs are nicer
but
otherwise kind of similar so uh so uh so
that's me um let's see does this pointed
work okay so my name is garnet Chan as
you heard uh I uh I'm now on the faculty
at Princeton um for but for most of the
last decade I was uh uh in the chemistry
department at Cornell
um so my talk today uh tries to look at
some of the intersections between
Quantum information Theory and quantum
chemistry I'm by training a Quantum
chemist but uh in recent years there's
been uh uh a lot of marrying of the two
fields and that's symbolized by these
two figures here right so one's I don't
know which one is which but one's
supposed to be common chemistry one's
supposed to be common information you
can see they're not really so different
they differ in fact only by one line in
PowerPoint um so uh I don't usually
think of myself as uh as working in
Quantum Computing uh rather I would say
that my group works at the uh works at
the intersection of qu chemistry uh
condensed ma Theory and uh qu
information Theory and and what we try
to do in our work is we devise a
numerical methods uh drawing on Concepts
uh from these three Fields uh to
simulate molecules and solids with with
high accuracy and with material
specificity uh now some of the problems
that uh we're interested in are shown
here uh for example uh I'm interested in
the area of uh strong correlation um
that's also the title of the next talk
you'll hear about from matus uh but but
briefly this is a scenario uh for
electrons uh when the energy scale of
the electron interaction
becomes large or dominant um and in that
case the traditional mean field picture
breaks down um we're also interested uh
in devising new simulation methods to
treat very large biomolecules or even
infinite systems such as condensed
phases including things like metal
oxides and superconductors uh and then
finally uh we're interested uh also in
Quantum Dynamics um this is what happens
whenever you carry out a spectroscopy
experiment in chemistry you shine
magnetic radiation on the system and it
relaxes and through its relaxation you
try to infer the properties of the
system so all these areas are uh
classic
oops all these areas are classic uh uh
problem areas in uh in chemistry and
physics and they all lie at the
frontiers of classical
simulation now um they of course uh very
challenging to to carry out particularly
for large system systems and so we
really have two choices so one we can
say the classical simulation is very
difficult and so consequently we should
try and go through the root of a quantum
computer and take advantage of quantum
Computing to make progress okay and of
course that's one of the reasons why
we're meeting here today um but the
other way in which you can uh try to
improve things is to say well perhaps we
can improve the classical algorithms uh
themselves uh indeed there's no
indication that the optimal classical
algorithms uh have been found um and so
a fruitful way to improve the classical
simulation arrogance is to incorporate
insights uh which have been gained from
uh qu information and qu complexity
theory in recent
years don't quite understand how this
clicker works so click to the
right okay okay okay there it is I think
it's to do with where I've clicked here
okay all right so that works now okay
all right so um so at the very heart of
it if you take away the uh sort of the
applications to the real gory chemistry
uh um qu chemistry is really concerned
with with three foundational or
fundamental problems okay so so the
first is a sort of existential problem
why can we do qu chemistry uh if you if
you think about the vastness of Hilbert
space uh that suggests that it should be
impossible to ever simulate qu
mechanically a large biological system
like a like a piece of DNA but the fact
is we do do that in practice we can do
that
at least within some approximations you
know reasonably well um and so why is
this um does this mean that nature is in
fact much simpler uh than we
expect um if indeed nature is then
simple this leads us to the second sort
of foundational question what are the
kinds of quantum States uh that nature
explores okay what structure do they
have um uh in in condensed matter this
is related to the classification of
electronic phases uh and then finally on
a practical level the third question is
uh if I know that there are certain
structures of quantum states can we take
advantage of that structure to carry out
efficient calculations uh and uh
construct new
algorithms so I I say that these are the
questions foundational questions for
quantum chemistry but of course much of
quantum information Theory concerns the
same questions um and so the two fields
are in fact uh in my view uh very
closely related even though the even
though not all practitioners
uh always think
so okay uh nonetheless the different
academic Heritage of the two Fields uh
means that uh quum chemistry and quum
information have come up with different
different kinds of answers to these
different questions um and it's and it's
exploring of the intersections of these
two of the different approaches which
I'm going to be concerned about in this
talk okay I'm getting confused by this
setup okay um so quam information and
quam chemistry V hbert space uh in a
complimentary way okay um and this leads
to different ways to characterize and
approximate Quantum States uh so so in a
nutshell uh the two views broadly
speaking are the following so the
formalism commonly employed in qu
information is to write your Comm State
Vector in occupation number
representation um in this case uh the uh
the Bas states are labeled by local
degrees of freedom these could be local
firmine occupancies or in other words uh
you can map to local cubits um the
important feature of writing things in
this form is that there's always a TENS
of product structure to the
space okay um the traditional view in ch
chemistry however is a little bit
different um in ch chemistry we
typically write a state in an excitation
representation now what this means is
you you take your complex qu State and
you and you write it in terms of
deviations from a simpler qu state which
you know how to handle this this is
typically a mean field State uh from
that mean field State you then uh add on
deviations or excitations um and uh um
in this basis the the excitations are
involve labels which label individual
electrons and so this is more of a sort
of first quantized view um also from a
mathematical perspective uh this
excitation picture doesn't really have
any kind of product
structure Okay so so how do we construct
approximations in these two pictures
well I'll start off within the
excitation picture which is the one
which is most familiar in chemistry so
we've seen this type of diagram already
in Jared's talk in the excitation
picture we say we start with a state
which is very simple typically a mean
field state which is which is made up of
uh single particle orbitals which are
all occupied and some unoccupied
orbitals and there's typically a gap
between them and then they add on the
deviations where the occupied Orit tools
are moved to the unoccupied Orit tools
okay um and the and the way to construct
an approximate Quantum state of course
you can you can parameterize any Quantum
state in this way but the way to
construct an approximate Quantum state
is to limit the number and form of these
expectations in some way uh and this
gives rise to many many different
theories in quum chemistry um probably
the most successful being couple cluster
Theory which assumes there's a certain
cluster structure to these terms so this
is a remarkably successful picture of a
lot of uh a lot of lot of nature
um you can do uh accurate couple cluster
calculations with accuracies rivaling
the best you can best things you can
measure on systems with with more than a
thousand orbitals okay we've been
talking earlier about doing simulations
and maybe 50 orbitals but if you're if
your Quantum State true physical Quantum
State happens to be reasonably close to
IM mean field State then you can
simulate many many many degrees of
freedom um um nonetheless it's clear
that uh this picture has to fail under
certain situations in particular if
we're in a regime of nature where the
typical interp partical interaction is
very large compared to this Gap okay
that's called the strongly interacting
regime then this mean field picture then
the mean field becomes unstable and this
excitation picture must break
down okay so that's how people construct
approximations from an excitation
picture what's the natural framework to
construct approximate approximations an
occupation number representation uh well
this involves uh uh some involves uh um
uh limiting the amount of the
entanglement in the wave function so
first let me say a little bit about
entanglement of course all of you know
about entanglement so it'll be very very
quick okay so uh so what's entanglement
well we know what entanglement uh what
entanglement measures uh to some degree
is how independent subsystems are in a
total system so imagine that we have a
system made of two cubits uh if the two
systems were in fact completely
independent then the quantum State uh
would just factorize okay and we then
would say there's no
entanglement okay now in the general
case uh the com state will not factorize
uh but we can write it in a factored
form by using a single value
decomposition in that case the qu state
is written as a sum of the components
associated with the individual cubits uh
and the number of terms in the sum or
depending on basically the singular
values here measures the amount of the
entanglement in the
state okay uh so from this perspective
I'm using entanglement as an analysis
tool if I give you a Quantum State I can
do an SVD on it and then measure how
entangled it is but you can turn this uh
viewpoint on its head and use it use it
as a way to construct approximations um
so for example you can say well why
don't I limit myself to consider only
those Quantum states which have a
limited amount of entanglement formally
this means that they have the
mathematical form that they can be
written as a sum over product terms over
cubits and there's a limited number of
terms in the sum okay so that's the
basic low entanglement
approximation okay um so this can be
generalized from 2 cubits to 3 cubits um
so in the simplest case if uh all these
things are independent then you say your
State factorizes uh but in the more
General case if I want to construct a
low in Tangent approximation I say it
won't exactly factorize uh but I write
my Quantum State as a product of terms
each associated with one cubit and and
have just a small number of terms in
this
sum okay so that's my low in tanglement
state here um uh you'll notice when we
write it out um it's missing a j here
you notice when we write it out it's
kind of a little bit unwieldy because
there was summing over all sorts of
indices and so on so so it's nice to
introduce a graphical notation um in in
this low entanglement approximation
every Cubit is associated with a
mathematical tensor some object with
several with with several indices and uh
I can write this tensor in the diag in
this diagrammatic form uh where each of
the legs represents one of the indices
and then the low int in this low
tanglement wave function I've just
connected those tenses together
equivalent to summing over these indices
I in a certain
way okay what do the Sig represent oh
those are singular values so if you were
to cut your system here pardon the
scalers uh yes this a diagonal you can
think of this as a diagonal matrix or so
scal okay yeah so so if you were to cut
this here these Sigma I would be the uh
numbers that enter into the ENT tment
entropy okay
so composition yeah so these are the uh
these are the Schmid numbers if you if
you were to decompose between the second
and third Cubit and the first Cubit
right and these are Schmid numbers if
you
decompose so
um okay so it turns out these low
tangent states have have a name um um in
qu information Theory they're called
matrix product States um but in fact
they have two names because it turns out
that this class of this class of quantum
States is a class of quantum States
implicitly explored by a very famous
algorithm in condensed matter the
density Matrix renormalization Group um
so the density Matrix renormalization
Group is is probably one of the most one
of the most powerful uh qu simulation
tools especially when your qu system has
a certain geometry kind of
one-dimensional geometry uh what has qu
information brought to the study of of
the dmrg uh what the traditional view of
dmrg was in terms of sort of statistical
physics language of
renormalization um and uh that's that
that really implied this linear
connectivity of these tensors but in
Comm information theory if we if we see
the dmrg as being just a certain
mathematical form or a certain graphical
form you can construct other
connectivities of the tenses which
generalize the technique to new States
okay and so uh so let's look at some of
these generalizations which are known as
tensor networks so here here I take my
cubit and I associate again with a
mathematical tensor but instead of two
legs I add three legs now um and you can
connect this now in more complicated
ways like you can connect to make a tree
um or you can connect it to make a
lattice and so and so forth okay and so
this gives rise to many many different
families of tensor Network States and uh
in total uh matrix product states and
their generalizations uh have
significantly Advanced ability to treat
strongly interacting systems in real
simulations because you notice in their
construction I never made any reference
to a mean field okay there's there's I
never said well let's start from mean
field and consider deviations from it I
just built the state up directly by uh
by linking together objects associated
with each individual
Cubit
okay um why tensent Network States uh
useful in nature so um so if the success
of the excitation approximations in
chemistry reflects the fact that
interactions are to some extent weak in
many regimes uh the success of tensor
Network States is a reflection of the
fact that nature is local okay so um the
precise uh so more mathematical
statement of locality uh is in terms of
a property of the entanglement known as
an area law which is a little bit
confusing but if you call an error so
I'm going to call a perimeter law okay
um so what's a perimeter law well let's
take an arbitrary Quantum system um and
let me cut it like this okay so I'm
going to have an inner region and outer
region and you can a question how much
entanglement is there between the inner
and the outer region well we know that
in physical reality is relatively local
right so in the sense that you know if I
if I tap something over there you don't
see something pop up you know on the
other side of the room um and so
consequently You' think that out of the
quantum States in A and B which are
entangled the ones which must be
entangled must be the ones that live
only along the perimeter okay and so
this can be turned into a more precise
statement which says that the
entanglement entropy of the system
system scales only like the length of
this boundary and this is a statement
which is uh essentially proven in one
dimension and which is believe to holdal
physical systems in two
Dimensions okay um so an implication of
this uh area law and implication of this
uh locality is that the corresponding qu
States can be efficiently represented by
these tens networks which have this very
very local entanglement Arrangement
right I just have these bonds which
connect these tensors on cubits
neighboring
cubits okay so uh so to summarize there
two families of qu states that we have
for efficient simulations in Hilbert
space are the following so um so this is
Hilbert space and we have two families
um we have the family of states that
arise from this occupation number from
information picture that uh that that
are computationally efficient because
nature is simple because entanglement is
local um and for these states as I
increase the amount of computational
resources I devote to the uh to to a
problem uh this allows you to capture
more and more entanglement okay uh on
the on on another side of the hbert
space you have the states associated
with the qu chemistry excitation picture
which essentially States nature is
simple because interactions are usually
weak and here uh as I increase the
number of the amount of computational
resources uh this allows us to extend
the simulations to larger and larger
values of the interaction parameter um
and the interesting question of course
for qu computing is to what degree uh
can can States reached by Quantum
devices the black boxes that Jared
mentioned to what extents do can they
live in in in regions outside of these
areas okay and that's not entirely
resolved okay um so uh for the rest of
this talk I'm I'm going to probably uh
just give you an overview um of what
applications of these simulations uh
techniques really look like in quum
chemistry um uh in particular to
different problems in coy so this is
this is an area which my group has
worked on uh uh for the last
decade okay so here's a very simple
application um let's take a fake
molecule made of the simplest atoms
which I hope you remember are the
hydrogen hydrogen is the simplest atom
okay I'm just going to stick all the
hydrogen together on a line so it's not
you know very simple and when I take
this linear type molecule if I stretch
it uh stretch you just stretch the line
um you you can show that that changes
the gap of the system and it moves it
from a weakly to a strongly interacting
regime okay so it's a nice test system
okay so uh so forly the hbert space of
this problem is very large it's 10 it
has 10 to the 28 degrees of freedom but
I can um I can uh ask the question well
is this is the Quantum state of the
system well approximated by low
entanglement wave function or matrix
product State okay so I can construct
such a low entanglement wave function by
writing down a tensor associated with
each Cubit or each atom and linking all
the tensors together okay that's going
to be my
approximation and what you see if I use
this kind of state to uh variationally
obtain the energy well uh here's a table
of numbers but what this index shows
here is essentially the number of terms
in the summation and here are various
Bond lengths as I'm stretching and you
can see these are the energies and the
energies are converged to all the digits
which really means I have at least as
far as chemistry is concerned an exact
solution of the problem okay even though
the Hilbert space size is very large why
could we obtain an exact solution well
it's because there's very little long
range entanglement uh in particular if I
have electrons in some Bond here they
are not entangled with electrons in some
Bond there okay so so this is a model
system and I can show you many more
things like this but let me now uh show
you some uh more realistic applications
and so I'm going to turn from the
hydrogen atom the simplest atom to
transition metals which are very
complicated atoms okay transition metal
atoms are very complicated because they
have things called D orbitals um and
these orbitals if you take sort of a big
atom these orbitals are sort of shrunk
to the inside of the atom and they
overlap very poorly with each other and
this gives rise to very small energy
gaps in the system and consequently on
that scale of the energy gap the
electron interaction appears to be very
large uh consequently transition male
systems have giant amounts of d
generously in their spectrum and give
rise to highly flexible electronic
structure they exhibit many many
different electronic States uh um it's
no surprise that these transition male
systems are both the most complicated
systems to stay in molecules as well as
the most complicated systems to stay in
physics so if you take any sort of
exotic phenomenon like high temperature
super conductivity it always involves a
transition
metal okay uh I'm going to focus on
transition metals in biology or
bioinorganic systems and we've seen some
of these systems already in various
talks um uh here are two very important
reactions okay photosynthesis which
Powers the planet right um so this in
photosynthesis uh light uh light is used
to convert water into uh oxygen actually
so I've got I've got this the other way
around but okay so Li convert and
um and uh nitrogen fixation okay which
which allows animals to uh to to
basically build up protein Okay so um so
in both these processes uh what biology
does is uh is something which appears
remarkable to the chemist so so Marcus
already mentioned that to carry out this
reaction what humans do today it's
actually the most important industrial
process today right the harbor process
you have to carry out at 200 atmospheric
pressure and 400° Cel and this just
occurs naturally in the root systems of
of legumes okay amb ambri temperatures
and ambum pressures simly photosynthesis
simly this reaction occurs with high
form efficiency and so how does nature
achieve this well it uses a very
flexible correlated electronic structur
transition Ms to carry out this
remarkable chemistry and it's one of the
big Unsolved Mysteries of our time
exactly how it's doing this if we knew
how it's doing this then we could try
and do it
ourselves okay so uh so so I would say
up to a few years ago trying to directly
understand the qu mechanics of these
systems was considered impossible but
with the Advent of very efficient
algorithm
that use these low entanglement
approximations we now we can now use
tensor networks or density Matrix re
normalization group to directly simulate
the many parle form mechanics of these
biological systems and study at them at
an entangled level so I'm going to show
give you two examples today uh I'm uh
from my work so I'm going to show you uh
a study on the oxygen evolving complex
in
photosynthesis um and a study on
something which is missing
it's
somehow I don't know what happened to
this image uh it's it looks more
interesting than this I can assure you
uh uh a a study of the ion cluster of
nitrogenase what is converting uh
converting atmospheric nitrogen into
ammonia okay so um one of the reasons
why it's been so hard to study these
systems quite aside from doing the qu
mechanics it's been hard to study them
experimentally even is because uh people
haven't really been able to crystallize
out the relevant proteins and they
people don't even know what where the
atoms are in these complexes um that's
not true well I'm it's for both systems
so oh no there's an x-ray structure two
years ago yes yes I know I know so I'm
going to show I mean traditionally it's
been hard right I'm say so now we've got
the structure okay
so I'm saying traditionally this has
been so so my point is one of the
reasons why it's been hard traditionally
to study these things is that you
haven't had a good structure um and it
may sound like a very simple thing to to
to just take the X-ray structure of a
protein but it's it's really really hard
if you examine uh the Nobel prizes in
chemistry over the last two decades
probably half of them go to structural
biologists where you can say all they've
done is wait for a long time till
something crystallize and then put it in
the okay in the differenter okay but of
course it's not as trial as that that's
only how theorist sees it so so amazing
thing about the oxygen evolving complex
is is last year uh an x-ray structure
Atomic res solution was achieved for the
first time uh by a Japanese group okay
so people finally knew where the atoms
lay um and so what we decided to do was
to try and study this system now not
just at the atomic resolution but at the
resolution of the electrons uh by
carrying out a dmrg calculation um and I
can't tell you everything about what we
learned from this calculation but it
revealed some very interesting things
okay so um so the first thing that we
noticed is that the cluster that they
that they studied uh it appears to be
damaged by the x-rays okay so uh so the
X-ray defraction structure is believed
to be in a certain State called the S1
state that just means there's a certain
number of electrons on the system um uh
but if you if you sort of study the
geometric parameters this is in
disagreement with some other
spectroscopy uh if we do if we actually
carry out the direct simulation uh we
show that we actually can show that at
this structure this S1 state is unstable
and it's actually a different oxidation
state of the cluster which is involed D
okay the S1 state lies on a different
potential energy surface so this is not
not that surprising okay when you stick
something in in you know a big floppy uh
organic uh biological molecule in the
X-ray machine even if you're very
careful it's not unusual for the x-rays
to knock electrons off the atoms and
change the structure and change the
oxidation state but our calculations
showed that this is what was happening
um we also did things like compute
various entanglement uh indicators and
and this is something about about the
reactivity I mean um there isn't a
direct link between entanglement and
reactivity but you have a sort of
indirect Link in the form of quantum
monogamy so you know that uh to some
extent if you have uh uh more Partners
you can be sort of less you can't be as
entangled with each with with with each
of them right that's the monogamy
theorem um and so could ask you um what
you even mean by entanglement because at
the beginning if you're talk I talked
about bipartite inang but you said from
the quantum chemistry point of view you
started from peration off the mean field
stage yes and uh that's not what I'm
doing here oh this is this is more from
the quantum information ordinary sense
of integr yes this is the ordinary so
I'm using here uh a I'm using here an A
A an approximate wave function structure
uh that's within the D Mar which is you
know in the occupation number form okay
so here I I compute uh sort of the uh uh
I I comp this is the quantity also which
Markus showed this I compute I guess I I
don't know the precise name of this
probably the two orbital Mutual
information is the right is probably the
right term okay um um and this Maps out
basically how all the different atoms
are communicating with each other in the
cluster uh and you can see that in the
different uh structures as the as the en
as the enzyme is going through its cycle
there's one atom which stands out as
changing very significantly in its
entanglement and people have been
wondering what is the atom in this
cluster which is responsible for doing
the chemistry well most likely it's
going to be this at
okay okay so so this this is of course
uh this is of course um uh just you know
just just a pre picture Okay a pre a
graph that's flattened out in some
pretty way um but on each of these atoms
we have a set of atomic orbitals um and
I compute the two orbital Mutual
interaction uh for every pair of atoms
uh so the two so um you them up what do
you
do m the mutual information is defined
between two orbitals and not two atoms
yeah yeah so so I so every atom has many
orbitals so you'll notice here mag for
these are the 5D
orbitals so you you collect all the
orbitals in in so the arrangement so the
precise arrangement of where the of
where these things are is determined by
the graph plotting software which is
just trying to make the graph look
understandable the question is every
circle is an orbital or is every circle
is an orbital every circle is one
orbital orbital and then the only
meaningful information is the labels of
the orits and the thickness of the lines
right the the relation of the orals in
space to each other is not important but
thickness of lines indicates the amount
of entanglement or the amount of mutual
information okay so you can see that
magnes 5 here goes from being
essentially not entangled anything to be
extremely strongly entangled okay in the
S1 State okay so this is the atom which
has a very big change in its Quantum
nature and most likely responsible for
the
chemistry okay so that's an example from
so so proximity Is roughly correlated
with the tanglement as
well proximity you said means nothing no
the proximity in the graph is not very
important but that's that's determined
simply by have you ever used things like
graph viz I mean you just put looking
you know how do you look at the manganes
and say that it's not there and is over
here oh so if you look at this here here
you see that none of the lines are very
thick whereas if we look at this
manganes oxygen it has a giant thick
line around so thick it's enveloping
both
okay but it it's not entirely clear to
me just looking at the that at the left
that it doesn't have a lot of lines
connected a lot of different oh okay so
yes yes okay but presumably adds up yeah
yes but so these are all really small
numbers and this is a you know it's a
giant number yeah I mean I'm sorry the
structure also changes yes the structure
changes yeah did you show us a two
structures no I mean it's not structures
yeah so for example in this graph here
so this is one structure is this is the
structure the X-ray structure and then
this is a relaxed structure which is in
the S1 state in the S1 oxidation the two
ATS that are strongly intended uh it's a
magnes 5 it's the one that's is on the
edge here it's one the edge of the
cluster
um let's see
so this one
here this one here or this one here or
this one here
in the left fing
only oh we call calcium one so sorry
sorry
yeah I'm before that's the experimental
thing it's not my
fault okay sorry these so the thickness
of the lines yeah these pictures is have
a singular values that appear in
sometimes in um so actually not so this
is a reduced quantity so you can get
this from the two par reduced density
Matrix okay um so um okay so so this
suggests that this is where the water is
binding okay um onto another system okay
so onto the nitrogen okay so um but then
but you don't feel like so the magnet
need to con into oxygen
8 does it change I mean that yeah I mean
yeah there there's also changes a lot
but magnes 5 basically goes from being
sort of un like not communicating with
anything to to to being sort of deeply
involved in the system this is not a
definitive this is by no means a
definitive proof I mean of course all
what what of course what you see is a
Theus is we calculate these things like
these two different structures we look
at this entanglement we go hm what what
can we say about it okay and it looks
like you know this isn't import there
seems to be a big change but should you
you look at at what happens if water is
really binding yes of of course we can
we should we should do more calculations
right I mean of course we we should stay
the whole cycle but and then there these
EFT calculations around by ZB yeah is
that also what he sees uh seonds
calculations also implicate
that sorry the statement was you think
that's most likely where water finds
because that's what you're seeing is
having the biggest change yes of course
so so there's a lot of context there
okay so you know why water why not you
know methane or something like that okay
so we know that some we know that what
this during these um geometrical changes
at one one at one stage of the
geometrical change what happens
biologically is the water comes in then
binds onto the cluster okay and so one
of the and so you would think that what
has happening in nature is the cluster
has changed so that one of the atoms
becomes available to bind water uh and
so we're hoping to see some echo of that
in the entanglement or in the wave
function of the cluster at different
structure so this is the basis of saying
that this is a possible water binding
site it seems be doing something it's an
indirect measure uh the more direct way
to do this is to do the next calculation
which is to stay the system with water
attached and all these other things and
that's of course you know what we're
going to do next is there any I mean is
there any intuition specifically as to
why having an increase in entanglement
with some other thing
Mo would make it a more likely Place
something to no no so no so I I mean um
this is why I just say there's a
greatest change in entanglement so all
this is saying is that the electronic
situation the electronic surroundings of
this atom are change is changing a
lot during this cycle okay perhaps it's
not being used for anything um
but you know it's the kind of thing
where you know if you see smoke then
perhaps something is going on
there isn't a direct uh there isn't a
direct in this calculation there's no
direct way to say that water is binding
there because there is no water in the
calculation are the ions moving in this
transition or is this just electronic
state is different uh the ions are
moving a bit they're not actually moving
very much it's actually you know they
just move a tiny amount if you were to
see the two structures you wouldn't see
any difference between them but you but
the interment changes a lot I see I see
so that's like a better measure in your
mind than just looking which part of the
molecule uh has it shape changing
locally the most well it's a bad measure
for me I mean the people of course who
study the system forever they're
sensitive to minute changes in the in
the in the system and
um I mean maybe for I mean I mean there
is a direct relationship between
entanglement and correlation yes and
correlation new forming bonds so this is
why you see the changes yeah so so you
see this you know you see these thick
thick things happening when there's some
this indicates there's some spin pairing
of the manganese with the oxygen and and
this is changed the spin state of the
magnet and then this might be preparing
it to be you know chemically active
but all right and we were just happy we
could compute the quantum State honestly
for this thing okay uh all right now
next onto the um Iron sulfur cluster
where there's a more definitive result
so
uh you very lucky with iron S no no I
mean this will be kind of bad we can't
see anything okay so I think this was a
this is a this is a Max PC
conversion you have a magnet if you want
move it's okay it's okay we can so just
imagine that there's some complex system
but embedding in it embedded in it there
are four iron atoms okay so um so this
is a very important system and uh you
have all these different ion syst ion
atoms which have spins okay you can
think of them as gigantic cubits they
have spins in five halfs um and they
form many many magnetic levels and the
the way in which people have understood
the magnetic levels in the system has
been very indirect I mean what you do is
you you do an experimental measurement
of something like the susceptibility and
this gives you some sort of vague featur
this curve and then you fit this
susceptibility to an underlying model
hamiltonian which you guess to back out
the magnetic levels okay so so this is
something which uh now a system which we
can just again directly simulate uh uh
with with uh with with the dmrg uh and
calculate these levels directly okay so
we these are the these are all the
singlet states that we get out um and
and they won't mean very much to you but
but the interesting thing that we found
when we calculated these singlet States
is that we didn't obtain the same number
of states which is a very qualitative
thing as what uh previous pictures
derived from experimental data had um
had said okay and actually usually when
a theorist get when a theor theory
disagree to experiment most of the time
your wrong usually in in theoretical
chemistry most of the time the
experiment is right but uh but it turned
out in this in this case when we looked
at it uh there was something wrong with
the experiment um so uh it turns out
that the hamiltonian that they were
using to back out their indirect data
was incorrect and um to uh uh to explain
it's actually very very simple um we
have four
irons they each get paired into singlet
so and and they're three so they're four
ions so there three ways of pairing it
and each of these three singlet parents
then gives rise to a ladder of
excitations uh sorry and and then
according to the experimental picture
each of these three pairings gives rise
to a ladder of excitations but it turns
out that when we went through and redid
the derivation that people had carried
out before but more carefully uh you see
that those excitations are not linearly
independent okay so the experiment was
so they're just over counting state okay
um and uh uh and if you see you look at
who did the derivation it was the
experimentalist so this just all we
learn is Never Trust experimentalist do
a theorist job okay all right so um so
the previous calculations were're using
uh the dmrg or the matrix product States
but more General tens networks are also
promising uh for example we showed that
a generalization called correlat Product
States could be used to describe
magnetism in these gigantic magnetic
molecules okay with lots and lots of
ions um and when you draw these Tre
tensor networks and they look like
should just naturally fit into molecules
like this ders and and these are very
interesting for their uh so their um uh
Optical properties um so I won't talk
more about this uh I should just move on
there are other applications of Comm
information ideas um for example Quantum
information has uh certainly in our
group significant influenced how we
think about the idea of quantum
embedding so this is a question where if
I take a very complicated system I just
cut out a small chunk how do I capture
the effect of the environment on this
small
subsystem uh now there's a traditional
physics way to think about this in terms
of greens functions and self energies
but from a Quantum information
perspective you say well all you have to
do to represent the environment is
understand the entanglement between the
two okay and this gives rise to a new
embedding formalism um also as I
mentioned we're interested in time
dependent simulations and we can ask how
does qu quom information inform them uh
just to show you very quickly uh the
final slide uh this is just to show you
that the embeddings based on
entanglement actually outperform
traditional techniques okay this is a
system a chemical system where we
compare against the standard uh uh
traditional physics technique dynamical
mean field Theory and the entanglement
embedding uh does much much better okay
so to conclude uh qu information really
has a natural intersection with qu
chemistry and I hope I've told you about
a few of those things which excite me uh
entanglement Theory intense networks
have already impacted real chemistry
okay real systems it's it's not just at
the level of model molecules it's really
things at the frontier frontiers of
understanding uh and ultimately um
though I haven't really said anything
about Quantum Computing I think better
understanding the limits of classical
simulation is essential to understanding
the limits of quantum simulation so
that's
up so we we do have time for a few
questions for any has
any Marcus yeah maybe you could also
comment on
say given the capabilities of say em
what would you say a quantum computer
needs to achieve in order to be
competitive in with the methods we
know in terms of electrons in negative I
really think that for low energy
property my okay so my personal feeling
is that for low energy properties of
materials and things like ground States
we have so many indications that
physical ground states are really simple
I mean except perhaps except for for
perhaps some extremely exotic thing
constructed in some weird low
temperature laboratory with some you
know peculiar topological properties
almost anything that you
actually certainly anything you care
about in chemistry uh isn't really that
complicated and it's that and for that
reason I I can't see the features that
people usually tout as being important
for qu Computing as impacting um the
study of these types of States now in
the case of the study of a Time
evolution of qu systems there we we know
that uh there we don't have similar
results to tell us that uh if we track
the time evolution of chome state that
it's simple in fact we have results
which show the opposite okay that time
evolve arbitrary time Evol Chom states
are complex and that's a regime where
Chom comput
are basically known to work well okay so
so um so I think that for qu Dynamics
there's there's a lot of room but for a
lot of the problems of qu chemistry
which are not dynamical it's it my view
is that there isn't my view is I would B
the you know I would stick with
improving the classical computer but
that's my
perspective are there other questions or
comments well before we thank gr let me
ask you a question uh could you turn
your last comment around and uh use your
knowledge of uh ground States and how
generically they're rather simple to
analyze classically or not that simple
but could you conceive of a
u a an example where the classical
techniques would break down rather
quickly so in other words uh can you
imagine you know some um molecule or
material uh where even to get at the
ground state you would need Quantum
methods yeah um
so uh most of
these so there's definitely systems
which are which remain hard um so so
probably the most difficult thing I
would say in the classical simulation is
that though you know representing the qu
State can can be simple uh nonetheless
finding it can be hard so If you're sort
of calling in a classical sense I mean
we we we often overlook this point if we
know we can represent the state well but
um if the sort of calling surface so
speak is you know very glossy uh then it
may be very hard to get there so so so
of course a classical computer has
problems with this but the qu computer
may also have problems with that um but
it might be that qu computer has
different problems and better ones I
probably Matas has some some views on
these types of this question as well um
you can definitely for make class of
states which which class computers have
problems with and then I think it's
still an open question if com computers
can do
that
yes in your H50 example OB that's the
one dimensional training dendr again you
have some simple geometric structure can
you com make a general comment about the
role of geometry in the success of these
methods yeah so I mean everything that
um you know everything people have
used to build in sort of simple
entanglement structures into a qu State
have in have induced a geometry on the
problem and uh it'd be very nice to
relieve this constraint every time I see
Duncan howan he says you know oh but you
know can you get rid of the lce or
something and then uh but I don't know
how okay so I don't know I mean I don't
know if it's a
fundamental feature or not but currently
I don't think there's any I me there
something dep that they get rid of
geometry in well yeah we've done some of
that for quantum chemistry but yeah so
so there's so other problems yeah there
are other problems so so like the so the
magnet the giant magnet that was also
using a state which basically
everything's connected to everything
else yeah they don't seem to work that
as well as the ones which
have well if there no further questions
why don't we thank Garnett
again
and uh the next talk is from a gentleman
you've seen
before requires no introduction thank
you okay so I want to now go away from
chemistry a bit more towards physics we
tried to invite more people from physics
but they
all had meetings at academies or in
bruss in Washington or somewhere so now
unfortunately I have to talk
again and I try to keep it in time so
that we can have the the the nice dinner
soon what we are interested in
is the material with with exotic
interest the properties that come from
the strong
correlations the most
famous example being
the
superconductors
superconduct dity was found first in
191 then it took nearly 46 years until
it was
explained first and then the big
surprise came that okay so
the high
temperature was about 30 Kelvin then
suddenly in 1986 it started jumping up
it jumped up to 140 Kelvin and has
remained there ever since the question
is why when it jump so high why can't it
jump just in another effect of two and
with room temperature and we have power
lines that are lost free in trains that
just Glide and so on there was this big
help but we haven't found it yet so we
might want to think about a quo computer
to get to give us a room temperature
superc conductor why a quantum
computer we can simulate these materials
with DFT it just gives totally
qualitatively wrong
States if you look at the undoped P
material of such a l Cate you look at
the band structure you see a beautiful
band the the the deband here crossing
the F surface is half a metal if you
build it if you measure it it's an
insulator it's just qualitatively
wrong so one has to
go
beyond the DFD and try to solve the the
the full Quantum problem what people did
physics first is we like to simplify we
like effective models that
capture the relevant physics so one
simplifies from the the the the material
one sees the ples ples of coer oxide
looks at them one goes further down and
finds out the relevant is the 3D 5 x² -
y^ 2 orbital so we make a simplified
model of just those orbitals we throw
away the rest the only thing we keep is
the the
hybridization between your
nearest Neighbors on the the square lce
and the Kum from n to the four terms we
keep only the local
U term so we go to a single so we go to
end terms and this is a simple model the
hubit model and as long as we don't
understand the hubit model there's no
reason we why we should understand the
full material I will then come back
later towards materials but even solving
that problem is exponentially
hard my Master's thesis more than two
decades ago was I should solve this by
Quantum of dealo and after day we
realize hey there's a sign problem
so I haven't solved my masters this
problem yet maybe that's why
I'm so interested in
this so what happens here
is the mod
transition and if we have a non-
interacting system then we have a band
that is half F in metal as we increase
the
local action the
density of stat changes as we make it
bigger and bigger and bigger the band
start splitting into two
subbands what goes on here is that if
the onsite theion U is very large the
electrons don't want to move just
because we don't want to have two
electrons on the
same ore to the strong
Kum repulsion and it becomes insulating
in the half field case the band start
splitting into two sub bands and this is
just not Capt Ed by
DFT when you have materials close to a
motorization important things happen
here we're looking at the
Lites and we're looking at the volume as
a function of
pressure and especially when you look at
your theum it has a huge change in
volume at the the the face transition
this just the more transition so a small
change in the structure can give you a
big change in the volume and it's worse
even in the the the actinite but I don't
want to focus on on them for
now H I don't know the temperature in
this case I know the temperature
for the okay so
for but so it's a bit above room
temperature
yes plutonium it's a few hundred degrees
is one of the uh isn't this one of the
issues with the uh maintenance of the
nuclear stof bar the phase transition
inum transition I think it's pretty well
known experimentally but properly
classified so I don't think you have to
understand it to keep it safe you just
have to measure it on sh get and to
observe it but yes one would like
temperature that's accessible because
standard what makes it interesting there
is that the most mlike material is
plutonium it's it it'ss right
there so but we don't want to talk about
that because we're not interested in
factoring of plutonium interesting
things that we can talk openly about and
that are not classified by someone so
look let's look at real challenges
superconductors I want to have a room
temperature superc conductor want to
model the super conducting properties of
the material these are tiny energy
scales these are
M like Vol scales or
less we want to start the
multi
fic materials with switchable Electric
magnetic elastic
properties topological materials with
unusually band structure topolog
inul to build our Quantum bits
maybe we want to have dce big
pigments non-toxic dce with the right
colors we want we we we really want the
accurate description
of transitions
between
localized
orbitals and we want to have non non
rare earth based near permanent magnet
so that we are less dependent on
China so there's lots to be done if we
can accurately describe such
materials
but it's hard on a classical machine
it's hard on a Quantum machine so we
want to do some hybrid kind of classical
Quantum method we want to either look at
the simplified model like
the the H model model solve that or we
want to mix methods we be used for the
the H model with DFD to make a Nega self
consistent DF plus strong correlation
solution and talk about that so first
how can we do these things on a Quantum
machine for the h model they've been
built their Quantum simulators
they've been tested validated they work
that has been one of the runers up for
the breakr of
the science two years ago they have been
tested so what is the idea here we can
by now control single Quantum systems
accurately single atoms and ions photons
Quantum dots and now we can't just build
a a Quantum model we can essentially
build a hubard model for example and
then measure on
it and this brings me to the
classification of computing devices the
first Computing devices were
analog the Greeks and the the first one
known as
the antique ter mechanism found in an
old Greek ship for the that that they
calculated the the motion of
planets this was speci purpose analog
nowadays we have a
programmable digital
machine what we're going to now is
analog Quantum machine Quantum simulator
want to build a hubit
model and then the next step will be the
quantum computer running Windows Q
that's my code name for
it so but let's first stay with a
Quantum
simulator what do we do there the first
example was a both einin
condensate we take the the idium gas we
cool it to nanal temperatures it's in a
met stable gas
phase and when you and at those
temperatures these are
bons they all condense into the same
ground state in a trap when you then
look at the momentum distribution
function you cool- it you see a sharp
Peak appearing Z these are all those
atoms in the same Quantum State at rest
that's the PO condensate all of the
atoms enter the same Quantum State and
that was first seen in 95 and gave the
Nobel Prize to the the C Cornell and
wman next one can take this and one can
add an optical lasers
and the optic L is from lasers on top of
it and then you have bons or fermion and
n atoms in the lattice you can build it
it gives you a huge Optical table lots
of lasers lenses mirrors and so on it
takes about 3 years to really calibrate
it get it controlled it cost a couple
million dollars to build then you have
it and you can take pictures for example
in a Quantum gas microscope of the the
the the the the gr group group they they
see here really in the theid atoms in
the lce
and one more thing I want to show is how
can we measure properties there
especially how if people measured
the momentum distribution function there
have a nice movie by the group of block
and it's very simple you start with your
cloud of atoms in the
trap now you just release the Trap and
the atoms fall
down as they fall down the cloud expands
and the faster atoms fly farther and so
after a while the distance from the
center is proportional to the the the
velocity or the the the the the momentum
so when you then take a picture you get
a picture of the momentum distribution
function roughly spoken you have to take
into to account that that did for
for short time only but then this works
and this can be done for bons this can
be done for
fion before doing it for fion the
challenge by Dara was to to validate
that it works for
bons we checked that we got from the
experimentalists
the the parameters which atom they used
the Trap the particle number the entropy
and we calculated what they should
see and and the challenge was that the
experiment should better reproduce What
We
simulate because the experiment is
supposed to be an analog quantum
computer for the model so it should
better reproduce the model and here's
the
comparison in the lce at high
temperatures that's just a broad peak in
the center when you go to low
temperatures more Peaks appear at like
multiples of 2 pi which are the
condensate Peaks and one sees the face
transition and the experiment is noisier
than the simulation but it works and
gives gives quite good
results now bons without a gauge we coup
to them we can solve they're easy to
solve and now we go to a hard
problem a high temperature
superconductor it's hard on a classical
computer it's easy on a Quantum machine
we just change the isotope we add one
more Neutron and the Bon turns into Fon
and essentially we use similar setup and
then one sees the the the F surface in
the momentum distribution
function but can we solve the problem of
room temperature super conductivity with
that the answer is no because cooling is
a real challenge we have to cool it to
tiny tiny tiny energies we would have to
cool it to P Kelvin and lower and
essentially they they just cannot at the
moment go low enough and even if they
can they can do habit model but not a
real full
material so one can make progress here
but so far the classical system
regulation methods keep
up
so but it's hard doing that on a Quantum
simulator and so i' prefer to have a
programable quantum
computer and here the scaling is much
better than the worst cas case I said in
the
morning because first of all for the one
body term we have the hopping the hoing
is local on this lce in this case there
is a way if we use twice as many cubits
we can do it in constant time it doesn't
scale with n the interaction is local I
have just n terms instead of n to the
four terms it's just the Hub
U but all terms can be parallelized the
hoppings of the odd terms in the X
Direction the even Bonds in the X
Direction the odd Bonds in the y
direction the even Bonds in the y
direction and all of the Hub use just
five steps and those five things can
done in
parallel so the scaling becomes constant
instead of n to the 4 log n therefore
improves well for the full column that
was my 10 the 9 * n the four times a log
n maybe and and more
factors here
we might have five terms so so there's a
five here which I turn into effect of 10
then I might then the other Advantage is
I'm looking only at the correlated band
and not the total energy so I look at
the much smaller energy
range but I still have to be careful
about
what ACC accuracy I want and I might
want a fixed energy but the total energy
grows with n so the error I want to have
should shrink with 1 / n so I get a
scaling of about 10 5 * n instead of 10
9 * n 4 and this now looks much more
realistic so here we can do big systems
Now 50 * 50 and we need such big systems
here because it's really
strongly
correlated and so we have a
a this here here this work with Brian
Clark Dave wer and
andak about how we can solve The Habit
model on a quantum
computer for the basic idea we take an
idea that we had
for
for Quantum GE
simulator we move it to your Quantum
your computer we take single plug heads
that we build then we couple
thematically and so build up the ground
state of the hubit model then we measure
what we
want to measure
your coration function spectral function
spectral gaps response
functions
super pairing and on systems of up to
eight sides it gets implemented and
coded and run on liquid by they they
work until show shows the liquid
tomorrow that way way
we can check how the the scaling goes
how slow we have to couple the pletes
that it works that the state
is prepared what is the cost for the the
measurements so and that we can do and
the think the H model should be
solvable now the H model has been called
a sperical cow
consider spal C of radius R it's a very
useful approximation for a physicist but
it's not relevant for any material if
you talk to a physicist they think it's
great if you talk to a material
scientist then I've asked one and she
said said okay if you solve the H model
i' be totally bored because it's not
relevant to anything now in the meantime
that has changed because I've challenged
her to build me a Hubbard model
material
but the methods we have learned so far
to you to solving the H model they can
be
applied to materials and as especially
something called the the
damic field Theory which is quite
successful for describing materials near
the transation where the physics is
local this is basically a mean field
theory on a Quantum
level so let me quickly review mean
field for spins you take a spin in a in
lce you you look at just one Spin and
the rest you replace by an effective
mean field then you solve that self con
consistently that the mean magnetization
of the spin should be the same as the
mean field coupling to
it in DMF you do do the same for a
Quantum model but now it's not static
but the electrons can hop you start from
a lce
model you pick out a single side or a
cluster of sides a cluster of your atoms
for example and then the rest all around
you replace by a self on system paath
and you let the atoms hop from the side
to the paath and
back and that way you greatly simplify
the
model and as long as the physics is
local like in the mod transition that
it's it essentially turns from
an from
an Tinder problem
to localized one then this is a pretty
the accurate
method and it can be improved by making
the by the using not just one side but
two or three or four or five sides for
the the the the
impurity what's the problem here I take
my ltis model from the lce model I
calculate the so so I take the bath
around I solve the bath exactly because
the bath is one of non electrons that
gives me a green function and then get a
side coupled to a paath around that have
to solve a single site coupled to a bath
once I solved that I measure the greens
function on the site and then I want to
find a lce greens function that has the
and then I look for a the lce model
that's the same local green
function so it's
uh mean fi
Theory where the self consistency is in
the local greens
function and the expensive part is still
solving that Quantum impurity problem
but this is now much smaller problem
than solving the full lce
model how do we solve
that on classical machines we made a
progress of effect of, 200,000 over the
last few years going to
new the color
methods that work
in continuous time and are quite fast so
there we make the not to error and that
allows us to go about the factor of a
thousand
faster what we can now do is well before
we needed the super computer to solve a
single
orbital D MFD that now takes just
minutes on a
laptop and on
a the supercomputer we can do five to
seven orbitals with the full
L the interaction and that way we could
look
at the F materials like serum people in
in in some the nation Lab look at the
the aconites but so we can go to up to
about 5 to
seven ORS
yeah um do you mean right here also non
non local exchange terms which a sign
problem yes okay there's no sign problem
because we we go into the I basis of the
localized cluster
those okay so we work in the the basis
of
the of the expanding in the coupling not
not in U but in t we expanding in the
hop into the paath and that's the key
here then we can do it okay but it means
because we have to go to the basis of
those those
correlated orbitals the scaling is
exponential in the size so that's why we
are stop at five typically in at seven
if we make some
truncations and that's our base in which
we do the the modal
then and so this one can do for
simplified models one can also do for
materials what we do there is we start
from the the
DFT
calculation we pick out a certain set of
local the the onee functions from the
bands which model the F or the D
orbitals and
then we pick out the those that we want
to model in a fully correlated way
we add in the full microscopic Kum
interaction a screened one which makes
it a bit harder for those but then the
problem is we have already counted the K
action because we already have it in the
DFT so we have to subtract the double
counting correction because we have
already treated the Kum term in the in
DFT and that's a bit and that's a
problem because that's at talk here
because not a pure F State it's an F
mixed hybridized with an S or a p so it
gets hard to separate it really
well but one can try
it and then one sees here for example
for
some the we go from theum vate over
calcium vate
to atum
titanate and as one goes here one
increase this is the ratio of the the
Kum repulsion the local U over the
bandwidth and at some point a gap opens
up at the surface it becomes the M
insulator LDA doesn't see that it's
that's the thin line
L stay
metal in L A
plus mft you see the map
opening isre experiment
experiment I have a slide that shows
some things from experiment as a spare
one which you can show and
it's yeah I have to unide this I didn't
no no they fine so here's some data from
experiment for the itm
Titanite that has so that's the the ne a
photo Mission Spectre and you see that
there's a gap here there's a Peak at
around - 1.3 electron volts if you go
here there's a peak around -
1.1 so it's roughly in the right place
for the ston in venerate that's still a
metal so it looks qualitatively okay
quantitatively semi
okay how did you obtain the u j andu
parameters that's a big problem here so
you have to is so that's one of the
problems you have to find out what is
the screen local keter action that you
should use for the
botel what I mean is I mean I'm not
saying that this is what happens in this
calculation but certainly some some dmfd
calculations the parameters are not
independent of the
experiment oh yeah so what you do is you
have the double counting and and you
just fudge your things until it fits
yeah right right and if it doesn't work
out you don't publish it
that's why I'm not doing this I'm
inventing methods for them to
use I've written one or two papers there
just to show that it works but then I
withdrawn again I don't know
yes the big problem is what is U how do
you get The Hub at U because it's not
the bare K interaction it's a screened
one it's screened by the other
bands
yeah and the J tery it's green so that's
the big problem how do you get reliable
values of U and J Let Me Show You
another slide
then which was just the next one that I
wanted to show that was a calculation
done with a simplified model so this was
done 10 years go be before when I could
do the full colum here interaction with
the the new methods
here invented at that time people that
was the the C group they looked
at the plutonium with just the H type
model just the U
term
and the problem in plutonium is that in
DFT the volume comes out in a gg8 comes
out 30% too
small it's just totally off in the
volume
of the unit of
the unit cell as you add a u and now you
you change the U as you change the U
the minimum changes and start shifting
and then it jumps up and this is sub
normalized here to the one of the of
theer once you have a u of about four
then it starts
agreeing and when you change the crystal
structure from FCC to the PCC that it
should be
then is the
lowest so that way you can start getting
at least qualitatively right answers for
the cor related materials but there are
still
challenges because we're limited to
about five to seven orbitals with have
the double
counting correction and it's hard to get
the U and the J parameters the skin
colum and the the H
exchange so and the double counting also
sensitively depends on how we choose our
correlated
orbitals because the band that I showed
is not just purely F it's f hybridized
with SN P so what can a quantum computer
help what if you can go to about 50
instead of just seven
orbitals we can avoid most of the double
counting Problem by including the SNP
bands as well and then it's much less
severe we can include a few more bands
and the screening problem becomes less
severe and the U is then more
microscopic
we can go to the bigger the the unit
cells like a
multi-layer your superconductor or the
alpha face of
your which is the the interesting one
the room temperature where there are
four atoms in the unit cells so I need
at least 28 orbitals to have just the F
orbitals
modeled and I can make it more accurate
by including more unit cells for the HB
model we've shown that if you want to go
to about room temperature you need to go
to about 100 unit cells to really get it
accurate so so here okay in the hardest
regions so here Here Again by going to
more unit cells one can make it more
accurate
so I see a big potential here for going
way beyond what we can do now just by
going maybe from seven already to 15
orbitals for which we might need 30
cubits 40 cubits we could do much more
okay so we need 30 cubits for the
correlated ones and maybe 100 simple
ones for the bath which is non
interacting where things just hop to and
back so we might need about 100 orbitals
in total or 100 cubits or 200 cubits but
the correlated Heart part might be only
about 15 orbitals and we have something
that goes Way Beyond what we can do now
and so here
things
can can work NE easily I'm not saying
that that will solve all the problem but
we go Way Beyond what we can do now and
so what we then want to do is you want
kind of a hybrid simulation LDA plus
dmfd plus quantum computers
to solve that and that can have the Bic
impact here the second way is models
like the the the hit models and so what
i' say what we should look for is kind
of some hybrid classical plus Quantum
methods where we reduce the complexity
of the quantum problem that we solve by
treating some things approximately and
then finding a good way to the correct
for it like in the mft and we need
something like that that also for
molecules
and other problem and that's what we
should maybe think
about so if you think I've been
pessimistic is just because first one
has to acknowledge that one can't just
do it boot for us and now we have to be
smart and find out ways how to solve it
thank you for staying for
listening
so you finished very prly we do have
time for questions we we have 6 minutes
for question then we should go to the
shuttle what is the complexity class of
the
model The Hub
model I think I can build hubard models
that are where finding the ground state
is at least NP
hard but but the simple Square L is H
model for the coup rates my believe it's
in bqp because nature finds the ground
set easily and the think go superc
conducting I can't prove it but that's
my feeling it's hard to ask that
question right cuz
you ask a question about scale right and
the H model doesn't have enough
parameters in it unless you play with
spin glass I can't put the H model onto
specialism and and turning it into a
spin glass I can build a spin glass from
the h model so then you have enough
parameters to ask that question
reasonably but then it's not the hover
model you want to solve because it's a
SP glass if it's the hover model you
want to solve there aren't enough
parameters to encode as essentially uh
enough problems to really talk about
whether it's so but the Hub model on a
square L this I believe because the
materials find the ground quickly I
believe it's in
bqp it might be P but I don't don't know
that
yet I don't know if I
cut so actually I had a comment on the
last sping BL thing had the question but
maybe I com so um so so there have been
a number of comments that about say spin
glasses and then there being problems
because uh one wants to find the ground
state and you know that's a trying to
find a true ground state in that case
it's very hard um but it might be
misleading I mean it might be that the
the hubwood model is some kind of spin
glass but nature doesn't find the ground
state that's um and and that's actually
a situation you see in in biology and
protein so for a long time the protein
folding field was concerned with finding
the ground state of a protein which
explores an exponential configurational
space and they worried about how to find
the ground state but the fact is in many
cases n you know nature doesn't find the
ground state just finds a met stable
State and so the the relevant physical
state is not the thermodynamic uh stable
state so perhaps you know one could say
I mean I'm saying is maybe we shouldn't
worry so much if if in nature there's a
sping glasson we don't have to the
gra if we want if nature have so if
there's a spin glass material and you
want to model it then yes then you might
just want to see hey it looks like a
spin glass and that's good enough and
nature can cool it much better but
that's it but then typically spin
glasses we want to solve because we map
an
optimization problem to sping glass like
on the d-wave machine and then we want
to at least get a good approxim a good
low energy State yes I think always
wants a good lry State need so so um uh
so I was going to say with respect to
hybrid approaches I mean um where you
treat some degrees of freedom
differently then then of course I think
um you know in chemistry this is what we
always do so um it's really a question
of Machinery that that hasn't been
transferred into solids it's just so
much
work but you talk with the Active Space
concept and so and so forth maybe I just
make a comment on what gar just
uh the distinction gar and the were
talking about finding the exact ground
state versus a good low energy State one
of the most important uh open problems
in quantum computer science is Q PCP uh
so it's known in the classical world for
about 15 years that U there are NP
complete problems for which it is just
as difficult to approximate the solution
is to find the exact solution and the U
quantum mechanical analogue of this is
whether this is true for qma complete
problems in general whether uh there are
hamiltonians for which it's just as
difficult to find an
approximate approximate ground state a
low energy State as it is to solve the
mix accut um so I don't think there's a
betting pool on this conjecture but it's
it's uh it's really like one of the key
open
problems
so just like a you see like a machine an
to DW starting with the H model and do
Computing you see we already have a h
model machine or many of them with
continue that with near Quantum gases
and so on and they work pretty well and
they get what we get and for all of this
static and thermodynamic properties
they've been a nice challenge for us so
that by now we have Quantum onal meth
like
the continuous time QC solvers for dmft
that essentially give the same results
so for thermodynamic properties these
experiments challenged us to beat them
and so far we've won for dynamic
properties like I mentioned it's very
different so there of course they win
because for for Quantum Dynamics we have
no way of doing it there's a huge sign
problem that we just can't solve except
for very short
times but these things so in those
things we take the atoms we use the
atoms to model the form and they
interact
by Fun interactions GL Jones like which
is short range so it's a cont
interaction it gives me a h VI but they
cannot really go easily Beyond
hu I could build a
dipolar molecule in a ltis that that's
what
people work now that way one can get the
dipolar coupling that's hard
but and and one can use irons and get
the the the unscreened colum but they
can't really build the theend structure
for a cpra this
way so to go to a real material the two
ways I either use the quantum computer
or I learn from the hab model about the
new classical method which it could then
apply to the the material we're trying
to go both rots now and see who will win
the quantum computer or our classical
ideas I think because of the time we
shouldn't
thankas maybe I should ask
real